allora quando l'ultima volta giocata
sixty seconds il problema principale è
stato perdere come tutte le altre venti
volte che ci ho giocato tranne una che
quella dove ha vinto pietro basta
cerchiamo di vincere questo gioco che è
impossibile che si possa vincere una
volta nella vita basta non ci credo alla
ragazzi avventura post apocalittica
difficoltà media e si vola non sa in che
modo potrà sopravvivere ma oggi oggi è
una giornata diversa oggi è il giorno 1
ce la faremo ce la faremo per i quattro
ottimo non si partì quasi mai in quattro
perché è randomico quando metti
difficoltà meglio per partire o in due o
in tre o in quattro ball in 4d culo ok
la partenza è buona ci ha detto bene
aver sentito che questo rumore di quale
si sposta mano è la maschera con busto
rumore
madonna che anzi non sapevo se stesso
roma va bene abbiamo anche un sacco di
roba raga abbiamo anche un sacco di roma
porca vacca e se ci pensate il kit
medico c'è la mappa c'è l'acqua e la
zuppa c'è manca solo la radio praga che
stavano fuori qualcuno subito con la
maschera immediatamente e vediamo cosa
riesce a trovare fuori esco vado al
giorno number one raga sono molto
contento di iniziare su sisti cycles
perché questa è la partita giusta vado
ci ha messo segnalino abbiamo giocato a
vedo vedo qualcosa che comincia per e ci
siamo divertiti un sacco per i primi tre
minuti poi tutti si sono stufati nella
lettera m
cosa medikit maschera effettivamente la
m va bene raga allora io manderei ted e
lo manderei assoluta all'altezza non
torna mai la noia senza sono schiacciati
e un peccato non abbiamo la tv per forse
potremmo usare le provviste preferite vi
siano materiale scenico
no non tipo non usate cose che poi
dovete buttare perché lo usate male
soprattutto perché adesso serve la
valigia perché il bando tende che non
porta mai un cacchio tel quando esce
cioè quello che fa più schifo però mando
ted con la valigia apre o con la mappa
aveva terminato maschera e mappa però di
ritornare zio perché siamo morti vai e
spacca tutto tranne la valigia che cosa
ci serve intatta che sono la riporti
sono capi allora non abbiamo più niente
guardiamoci negli occhi per tre giorni
ragazzi ok sono abbastanza veloci i
primi giorni ragazzi perché non abbiamo
niente si è portato via tutto ted e a
parte dar da mangiare non possiamo fare
nulla a meno che non succeda qualcosa
tipo questa non è anche perché non
possiamo interagire non abbiamo oggetti
quindi nn è una partita strana raga
perché abbiamo solo acqua cibo e mac kit
e la mappa quindi non abbiamo perché
mente nulla se non le è essenziale che
non è male perché le volte manca anche
quello dei ragni ora di agire per i
ragni no non agiamo non agiamo per i
ragni tenetevi i ragni e tornato ted è
tornato abbastanza velocemente ha
spaccato la maschera buttato la valigia
e non ha portato un capo ottimo bravo
ted direi ragazzi di dare acqua a tutti
tranne attendo che non ha sete e del
cibo si vede che abbia avuto in giro e
del cibo a tutti quindi a questo punto
non manderei nessuno fuori perché non
abbiamo più la maschera vignette
spedizioni ce l'abbiamo nel culo calzi
l'escrow a meno che io non mandi fuori
qualcuno perché tanto poi tornano i
medici ci fanno di iniezione potrei fare
questa cosa però che sarebbe male ma se
dicesse che c'è mando veramente fuori
qualcuno dolores ad esempio quando
dolores non c'è tempo di pensare ora
delle domande accendiamo la radio vai
partiamo chiamando subito l'esercito che
non arriverà mai quindi chi se ne frega
perché la mappa la radio servono per
contattare loro ma fine non aiuta mai
nessuno non serva un cazzo però
proviamoci lo stesso vai vai tieniti
rilavati accesa dai porca vacca
sintonizzatevi su radio maria e speriamo
guarda quanto tempo e fuori dolores che
c'è su pista il governo ha annunciato di
radio che evacueranno ok ma i jeans si
infuria trono ha saputo che non le
sarebbe toccato neanche una goccia
d'acqua fuori quando è fuggita
nell'andare isolata ma era disidratata
non avevo visto ma non avevo visto scusa
per jane scusa provvista e meno a una
che non le merita le lobby che mi
dispiace scacchi non avevo visto dottore
mi ha portato del cibo stavo veramente
esseri merda cibo cioè da presa una
gliel'ho data una bella presa un'area
perfetto meno uno più uno l'ex croce
d'onore se non si è ammalata non si è
ammalata timi subito va a correre i
pentiti e disidratato non perfetto con
ricky mib itunes e ho avuto un cul
incredibile non si è ammalata c'era una
probabilità su milione che non si
ammalasse perché le radiazioni sono
ancora altissime e lui ha fatto niente
incredibile è anche vero che ha portato
una scatoletta a2a quindi un cazzo è
prova bel messaggio radio dell'esercito
ok desiderosi altri nel piano di
evacuazione già fornite le coordinate
geografiche per raggiungere il luogo che
vai da una mappa è let's go ragazzi spa
è tornato è tornato è tornato come cazzo
ti chiami figlio e capelli ai dovete che
lui è un genio del fenomeno da fenomeno
il fenomeno è un grande ma che cazzo
bisogna dire un fenomeno del fenomeno
porta fa tutto lui fatto se il
capofamiglia se il capofamiglia la gente
non ho questi qua non lo sanno ma sei tu
il capo sei tu il capo ha ingenerato to
the head prendi le redini di questa
famiglia pagato le tasse non lo so anche
l'acqua anche le carte favorito e la
valigia ma si dai ragazzi si adatta alla
rinascente a far shopping cos'è cos'è
che luccica le tue tasche team io no
formiche mutanti ma certo hanno fatto
così prende un colpo dolore se lei vuole
vuole ferire a quei matti mi dice di
voler avviare un allevamento di formica
tomic e dolores temi stai zitto non
rompe il cazzo c'è mancato le formiche
giallo abbiano cibo noti mia malato a
perché gli ha morso invito a tim e
quindi niente vabbè dai vediamo come si
a tutti e due sono malati forse arriva
di medici a fare la puntura e speriamo
perché non voglio usare i mezzi kit kat
i tipi non a me l'aspetto terreno per la
ricerca di chiari simulare va be dead
dimmi che portato roba per l'amor di dio
ho mica incredibile come lui sa fare
qualcosa guarda guarda che rapaci per
sul peso fenomeno non l'avrei mai detto
bravissimi rarissimi tutti ma la tutti
morti stanno morendo tutti va bene
medici è gradato una bottiglietta
d'acqua nel 2000 le 18 magari sempre
arrivate a darci nella punturina non so
non sarebbe male visto che sono tutti i
malati allora usare il kit non è male
come idea che stanno venendo tutti ma
che gioca taesa dicono i medici curano
tutti sarebbe incredibile ragazzi ok
rack e allora provo a fare una cosa
facciamo questa cosa al sì come ted
emesso di merda dolore sarò a faccia
così curiamo dolore curiamo dolores ma
andiamo fuori lei e poi vediamo che
succede l'unica lavoriamo sei perfetto
usiamoli me il mac intanto almeno
offrono un fucile per delle carte subito
perché se le scie chimiche
immediatamente fucile per delle carte
subito gatti giorno 40 ragazzi se adesso
mando fuori dolores che ha posto
teoricamente ce la dovrebbe fare uscire
a fare qualcosa per esempio sarà
spacciato baiola res devi portare un mac
it dolores giorno 41 l'ex co
chair curati ci hanno curato incredibile
incredibile c'è ancora di medici ha
funzionato ha funzionato ramente oggi
hanno fatto le iniezioni se stava
schiacciando fortissima no veramente
morti stile va bene c'è più che altro
ted ditemi quello che volete ma la gioco
è almeno quello che mi sembra abbastanza
entusiasta era studiato di stare vai tu
dimmi perchè se aspettiamo gli altri
giorno 50 non male comunque normale sta
partita la spedizione stanno andando
bene finché non ci siamo corti cano che
fare con un branco di velociraptor e
anche se non lo erano la famiglia e le
bestie eguagliava quale i dinosauri
abbiamo scoperto a nostre spese è morto
team
va bene non ho capito niente ma ok va in
onore scola maschera perché dire no devi
portare qualcosa non mi chiede cosa la
porta qualcosa 54 laga sta diventando
bello peso nessuno ci vuole aiutare una
partita a senso unico questa ragazza
durante l'ultima spedizione abbiamo dato
un carro armato abbandonato sembra
adagiata potrebbe contenere provviste
veit ed tanto sei malato come la merda e
quindi va beh chi se ne frega
bene è morto è esploso col carro armato
cosa è successo
così su cechov è morto non ci
aspettavamo dicendo un'esplosione norma
che ha sentito i frammenti di cadere dal
cielo e colpiranno a stagione la dimora
il mezzo ha disseminato di trappole ma
dai è
esploso il carro armato ottimo signori
questa è la sexy secondi oggi non una
vittoria ma un alone sconfitta
iscrivetevi al che aveva lasciato un
commento io vi piace e noi come sempre
ci vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]